foreign
so a couple of years ago I went through
a pretty brutal breakup and to keep
myself distracted I decided to set
myself a ridiculous art challenge to
create the closest thing to a real life
time machine with very little technical
experience in the bank account of a
college graduate now I know this sounds
crazy but avoiding your feelings is a
very powerful force and I had a plan you
see all I had to do was to spend an
entire year wearing 3D cameras on my
face record my life in first person for
365 days transfer that into a series of
hard drives and then build a virtual
reality simulation that would let me
experience those memories in 3D that's
all I had to do
in other words I was going to create a
personal time machine a virtual reality
invention that would let me go back in
time and experience moments from my past
and building this was pretty insane I
had to learn a lot of technical skills
in a really short span of time and for
an entire year my Tinder profile looked
like this
but in the end it was all worth it
because the final result was so much
cooler than I could have ever imagined
so this is how it works you put on a VR
headset you select the date and time you
like to go back to you pull the lever
and then bam I got to see exactly what I
saw at that given point in time and in
this case I was eating a bagel on a tree
which was the thing that I used to do
and now I could go back in time and we
experience the past trip try a mule
again for the first time and even hang
out with a friend who's no longer with
us and the longer I spent you know with
this time machine the more I realized
that I had accidentally built something
that was much more meaningful than I
initially imagined because this wasn't
just an entirely new way for you to
experience your memories this was an
entirely new way for you to understand
yourself
as I use the time machine I started to
become hyper aware of how much of our
Lives we forget over the years and how
important it is for us to enjoy the
moments we have before our minds
inevitably forget them I learned to be
kinder to myself as watching myself
wander through life in third person kind
of taught me how much of a dick I am to
myself when things get rough
and
I even started to have an active
friendship with myself as in many of my
recordings you'll find me talking to
Future me sending thoughts hopes and
feelings across time
and this was really cool and it was also
really confusing because I was just
trying to get over my ex with some art
but somehow by mixing art and Technology
we ended up in a really interesting
place and the world agreed The Time
Machine went super viral 50 million
people saw it and it even inspired
people to start entire companies based
off this concept so it seemed that by
mixing art in Tech I created something
Innovative by accident and because that
made me feel pretty good I was like can
we do that again
could I just take emerging technology
you know the stuff that's weird the
stuff that we don't understand do some
art and just accidentally innovate and
so our Journey Begins a couple months go
by and ladies and gentlemen I was back
in the game I had a new girlfriend her
name was Max and things were going well
and Valentine's Day was just around the
corner so me being me I decided to gift
her a little bit of in our project so
whereabout deceives what I can see from
my perspective I'm wearing an AR headset
that's tracking her body in real time so
here we go
yeah
so love is a really abstract feeling
it's something we all feel but we can't
see or hear so I created this experience
that turned the touch Between Two Lovers
into this Visual and auditory Symphony
basically transforming intimacy into
visuals and sounds which I thought was
pretty cool and Max got to play me too
which I think she liked but when I
posted this online people started
telling me that I had built something
completely different and that is when I
realized that by engaging in this
artistic exploration of intimacy I
created a new kind of musical instrument
a particle synthesizer that lets you
play complex sounds in midair like this
[Music]
no no
pretty cool right
wait we're not done just for good
measure I took those instruments and I
attached them to a piece of clothing so
I could now play my own clothes with my
hand in midair which is ridiculous and I
think it's the first example of
interactive digital musical fashion so
For Better or For Worse art took us to
some really interesting ideas and at
this point I thought I was onto
something but then I had another breakup
so
but it's okay because an artist can do
what an artist does best which is to
turn heartbreak into art so Jokes Aside
this was actually a really difficult
time in my life because not only I was
going through all of that emotional
turmoil I was also moving to an entirely
new country I was leaving my hometown
from Brazil and moving to into the
United States thousands of miles away
from family no friends didn't know
anybody so it was probably the loneliest
I've been my entire life
so why not use this opportunity to take
my misery and make something cool
what if we use VR to create an
experience that's specifically designed
to Foster the connection that I needed
to make me feel closer to strangers and
that was the Genesis of where thoughts
go so this is how it works you enter
these virtual worlds in which you're
surrounded by these sleeping creatures
each one of them is a voice message left
by another user who was there before you
were if you raise your fingers and touch
them gently you can listen to the voice
messages that people have left behind
and in each one of these worlds you're
asked a different personal question so
by playing this experience you're
essentially going down an intimacy
funnel in which you're getting to learn
about deeply intimate aspects of other
people's lives and of course at the end
of each one of these worlds you can put
your hands together give birth to your
own little creature speak into it and
leave your messages behind for others to
find
it was sweet beautiful Anonymous and
people would say things in this
experience that they wouldn't share with
their closest friends and when I was
making this everyone told me it was a
horrible idea people would tell me that
trolls would destroy the entire app that
people would be mean to each other that
people would make each other cry and you
know what they weren't wrong
wait so when I started testing more
thoughts go with the first couple of
hundred users I found out that roughly
20 of them were crying at least once per
session this is what I like to call
where thoughts goes cry rape but people
weren't crying because they were being
bullied people were crying because they
were feeling emotionally moved by the
messages of others we had created a
system that instilled the Deep sense of
empathy and connection in a really short
span of time and by making this not only
I was able to get the connection that I
was craving but I was able to give it to
others as well
and because how this experience was
designed there were virtually zero
trolls in the system it's like people
were walking into a church and
instinctively knew to lower their voices
treat each other respectfully and treat
the space they were in as sacred which
is a cool thing you can only do in VR
and when I you know when I put things
that way it's clear that there's
something interesting here some
innovative ideas that could be used you
know designs and lessons and approach
that could be applied towards the entire
internet but at this point you might go
like Lucas you're not really innovating
anymore there's a lot of thought behind
this and yes but no because a year after
I launched this medical doctors
contacted me and told me I invented a
new form of group therapy and now this
art piece is being used in a medical
trial as an anxiety treatment tool and
shortly after that I got to collaborate
with SpaceX and Saint Jude's to make a
version of this that astronauts could
use so they could emotionally connect
with kids on Earth this is not what I
was trying to do
thank you
but that's when it started to make sense
and it's really simple when you take
technology that we don't understand and
you approach it as an artist you do
things that the conventional engineer
would never think of doing and when you
do that in a space brimming with
possibility like emerging Tech it's only
a matter of time before you stumble upon
something of value that is why mixing
art and Tech is a great way to
accidentally innovate it takes you off
the beaten path it removes creative
constraints and it allows you to
approach technology in a way that's
unique to you that leverages your
passions and your interests and your
life events and breakups and all of this
just comes together and gives you a
unique angle of approach and that unique
angle is everything because here's the
thing about emerging technology and this
applies to everything VR AI brain
computers and whatever's next
no one knows what they're doing everyone
is just following blind hunches it's too
early in a Technology's life cycle for
anyone to have a comprehensive view of
what it's good for and in a world where
no one knows what they're doing just
following your gut is a really great
thing to do because what we have here is
unlimited creative potential it's the
ability to create impossible objects out
of thin air at no carbon costs the
ability to connect people in ways never
possible before and it's the ability to
create technology that changes how we
look at ourselves in the world around us
we have all the tools we need to create
a future that's beautiful and human and
exciting and the only thing that
threatens this is if we have a massive
lapse of imagination
so
today I'm working on a new project
called pillow and I'm trying to turn
your bed the most comfortable place in
your home into a mixed reality
playground of Wellness play and human
connection and this is an early
prototype but
look how beautiful this is we're using
mixed reality to connect two beds
together and give people a way to engage
that's never been possible before
and even though this is early there's so
much that we're learning about how to
create meaningful connections between
people and virtual environments how to
use artificial intelligence to create
immersive experiences that really feel
personal and how to approach products
with accessibility in mind from the
get-go things that work just as well
lying down on a couch as they do in a
hospital bed
and I don't know where this is going to
go but it's going to be somewhere
interesting and when I look at this I
just don't see art I see research I see
things that could be turned into
products and companies and I want more
artists to start tech companies we need
more artists in technology but we also
just need more technologists to think
like a little bit like artists
because some of the world's most
important ideas you really can't stumble
upon them by just trying to chase the
highest valuation sometimes you only
stumble upon them when you approach
technology from a place of Truth when
you build things just because you need
to make them and you don't know where
you're going but if you follow your gut
you will be rewarded and I don't know
how or when like with anything else that
I told you about today but you will be
rewarded we will all be rewarded
and being true to yourself is just a
really good long-term strategy
technology gives us the tools but art
shows us the way it's always been like
this it's hard to find a single
futuristic startup that hasn't been
deeply inspired by some kind of Science
Fiction material Engineers have always
followed the imaginations of artists and
that's not going to change anytime soon
but what is changing is that technology
is becoming easier to use I didn't know
how to do any of this five years ago
artists don't have to be in the
background anymore we can get our hands
dirty and build science non-fiction
instead to create projects and companies
that challenge the engineer dominated
visions of technology and propose
something new something a little weirder
with a little more heart and I think in
the process we can unlock new realities
that not only we're excited to live in
but that we're excited to see our
children grow up in for the longest time
in technology artists imagine so
Engineers can build but I think
engineers build so artists can imagine
so if you have a crazy project in your
back pocket something you always wanted
to do but never got around to you should
go for it you will never know where
you're gonna find on the other side
thank you
[Applause]